We have seen that DRAM accesses
are slow, because really we have to use
the row decoder to select the row,
then get those bits onto the bit lines,
then sense what's on the bit lines,
and so on, and
only then we get the values in the row
buffer from which we can read them and
send them back to the processor.
But not all of the DRAM
accesses have to be that slow.
So we will discuss a technique
called fast page mode,
that makes some of the DRAM
accesses a lot faster than others.
Remember our organization of the DRAM
with some part of
the address to select a row.
That row of bits gets output
to the sense amplifier.
We then latch those into the row buffer,
and then from the row buffer,
we use the column address
to select a bit to output.
And then, from the row buffer,
the column decoder,
using the column address,
selects the actual bit to output.
Note that once we have done all of this,
the row buffer can retain
the entire row, so if we want
to read a bit from the same row,
we don't need to go through the whole
row address, sense amplifier,
row buffer mechanism again.
What we can do is simply keep what
we have in the row buffer and
just change the column address.
Then the bit simply gets read out of
row buffer without a new DRAM access.
So this approach of finding
what we need in the row buffer
is call is fast-page mode.
It's not called fast-row mode just
because some people prefer to call
a memory row a page.
It usually has thousands of bits,
so people call it a page.
It has nothing to do with the pages
that we use for virtual memory.
It's just a name for something that
has a lot of bits in this case.
So fast-page mode works this way.
We do what is called opening up a page.
That amounts to providing a row address,
selecting a row, sense amplification
of what the cells output, and latching
what we get into the row buffer.
Now we can do a series of reads and
writes to the page,
which really happens to the row buffer.
We can read or
we can modify bits in the row buffer.
Finally, when we want to do
something on another row in memory,
we do what is called closing the page.
We now use the sense
amplifiers to write back
to the row what we
have in our row buffer.
It could be different data than what we
read because we have been modifying it
also in between.
And this way if we want to do a single
read we would have to open up page,
do one read, then close up page
to write back things to our
memory cells because of
the destructive read.
And then finally we have to do what is
called closing the page, which amounts
to writing the data from the row buffer
back into the row from which we read it.
So if we want to do a single
memory read, we would open a page.
The data is now in the row buffer,
and no longer in the row.
Do the read from the row buffer and
then close the page,
which causes the data to be sent
back and written back to the row.
We can do a single write,
which amounts to opening a page,
the data now ends up in the row buffer.
We do a single write, so
we modify a bit in the row buffer, and
then we close the page which causes
the row to get the new data, and some of
the bits may not have changed, which is
why we had to read in the first place.
But we can do a lot more than just
one operation in between opening and
closing a page.
So usually, it's advantageous to
open a page, do all the reads and
writes that we can to that page before
we close the page and open another page.